all my life i've dreamed of getting out
there into space
now that was a challenge for me because
i went to 13 different schools
and i have a condition called dyslexia
today i want to talk about three fellow
black scientists
one from the past one from the present
and one for the future
all pioneers in their field my first
hero
is unfortunately no longer with us his
name was alan powell goff
he was born in kingston upon thames in
1920
his father was jamaican and his mother
was english both his parents were
physicians
like me he was inspired by his parents
and gave a degree in medicine
and a diploma in bacteriology he went on
to specialize in pathology
the study of the causes and effects of
disease
in the 1950s measles was described as
the greatest killer of children in
history goff's work on vaccines was
revolutionary
in ending the measles epidemic a sample
of the virus is taken
and then weakened usually by reproducing
it many times
this creates a living but weakened
version of the original virus
which the body can fight stimulating
long-lasting immunity
he also worked on the polio virus and
made important contributions
to the development of a vaccine for this
too
tragically he died young in a sailing
accident
aged just 46. dr goff was a true pioneer
but few people know his name and with
the important role that vaccines are
playing in our lives today
it's wonderful to celebrate the work of
this fantastic man
a present-day scientist who i think you
should know is dr asmaret
asafal berhay she was born and grew up
in eritrea
sadly when asmaret was young her country
was undergoing
a war of independence despite this
turmoil
she was one of only a thousand students
admitted to university in
eritrea when she left school she studied
soil science
and was fascinated by ecosystems within
the soil
her childhood experiences led her to
conduct research
into the effects of land mines on soil
looking at how the explosions cause
disruption
in the structure of the soil and how
they can leak toxic chemicals
into the soil she also worked out that
if just a quarter of the land mines
from the affected areas were removed
that this would enable the land
to produce enough food to feed 1.6
million people every year another
brilliant
black pioneer her work inspires me
because in my early career
i worked on the development of a
handheld landmine detector
also trying to tackle the same problem
but from a different angle
now a scientist you should look out for
is kaisha payne
like me kaisha grew up in london and
showed an early aptitude
for science and maths it was chemistry
that most excited her
she loved the idea of studying the
fundamental building blocks
of everything this passion led her to
undertake a degree
in chemical engineering she was the
first member of her immediate family
to go to university kaisha was a process
engineer
at astrazeneca in cambridge this is
where one of the covid19 vaccines was
developed
kaisha's work focused on ensuring that
drugs that were being developed
didn't degrade by the time they were
administered to patients
throughout her studies and her career
she was often
the only black person in the room
passionate about having more diversity
in stem
kaiser created the black british
professionals in stem
a network for black students in the uk
to connect with their peers
and receive advice and mentoring from
black british stem professionals
as she says when you don't see yourself
represented in an industry
it's extremely difficult to believe
there's a place for you in it
these three black scientists didn't only
dream of a better future
but had the determination to make it a
reality
i'm truly inspired by these amazing
people
and i'm excited by what the next
generation will achieve
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video